All right.
All right. Good afternoon everyone. It's
great to be here. So today I'll be
talking about our learning and
experience of hunting for geni threats
at scale using yara like signatures.
Since uh previous talk was about to
rules, I'm assuming you guys are
familiar with it. Just to be sure, can
you please raise your hand if you have
heard about Yara or used Yara?
All right. Awesome. So that's good. So I
am with the right audience here. So as
you probably know, Yara is the gold
standard for identifying malware
binaries and JavaScripts like scripts
and it's being used everywhere including
Palo. We detect millions of uh samples
every day using Yara rules.
But with the all the agents doing the
work and geni being the mainstream now
the new binary is natural language. It's
no longer pees or scripts.
Even though Jara is great, they are not
good at detecting jai threats.
That's where superara comes in. We built
our library getting inspiration from
Yara just like Yara so that you have
very minimal learning curve but it can
work to detect geni threats. So I'm
going to walk you through what I mean by
geni threats and show you some examples.
The best way to learn something is
through examples. So I'll be uh tossing
in few examples and showing you how it
works. And first the number one thread
in genai is prompt injection and you
guys are probably familiar with that and
it can happen from multiple ways. Since
I work in the web space I'm going to
focus on the examples which I see
day-to-day from the the overall internet
web space. And these prompts can be
delivered through uh query parameters or
they could be uh uh delivered through
hashes or it could be even through
dynamically detonated into the browser
itself and none of the uh firewall
solution will not see it because it get
to the browser and the browser itself
calls the the LLM and gets the obuscated
JavaScript and does the the bad stuff.
So now enter into the new startup called
safeinttel.ai.
It's the rising new startup which takes
any LLM and instantly convert into a
safe LLM to use and they provide API
access and their lead engineer adder
decided that we need to have some
solution to make sure that users do not
misuse their query parameter based API.
So she came up with this uh solution.
She iterated multiple times and she
developed this yara rule and as you can
see she figured out it quickly get out
of her hand. The number of op parameters
started increasing and it became
complicated. It became difficult to
maintain to catch all the variance of
prompt injections and worse yet it is
prone to FP and FPN uh uh as well.
So she was scratching her head and she
was then came across this awesome
library called Superior and she was able
to write the same rule with just these
two lines of code where you specify what
you want to catch in natural language
and the library does the magic by doing
the semantic match internally and you
don't need to iterate all the varieties
or all the types of injections here
because it can understand the semantics
and identify very similar one. For
example, don't execute previous rules.
It will understand even though it is not
specifically mentioned.
Now the test of time. So now she
converted into this one. She put it into
shadow prod. Now she want to make sure
that it works. Meaning it can detect
more threats than it was able to detect
before. So as you can see the tradition
uh clearly compared to the traditional
Yara rule the semantic Yara rule the
super rule was able to detect more so
she was happy about that and at the
little expense of little bit of a higher
expense because it need to do semantic
matching but it's it's still cheaper
compared to doing some kind of LLM
because we have the habit of throwing
the LLM to every problem. The problem is
when you want to detect uh uh threats at
uh scale when you have to iterate
through millions of pages they don't
work that's why you need to have
solutions which works intermediate and
so one thing she realized though there
is still room to improve as you can see
they were not able to identify row
override so that's a valid uh limitation
and she's right about it that's where we
introduce various other conr contract
which will make sure that you can even
uh detect much harder injections. So
specifically we support four types of
construct. The string is very similar to
the Yara rules that we already have
seen. And similarity is the one that I
showed you in the previous slide where
you can do semantic similarity with any
text. And then you can throw in any
classifier which has either binary or
multiclass classification and ask it to
use it as a the rule uh
uh condition and also you can write your
own LLM prompt and ask it to use it as a
detection engine. And as you can see the
detection efficacy increases as you use
these different models down the line but
at the same time it also increases your
time and cost. So just like in security
we use defense in depth. Our
recommendation here is to use a mix of
these uh techniques so that you balance
the efficacy and the detection cost and
time so that you cover as many as threat
possible but without breaking your
wallet.
All right. Now I'm going to demonstrate
uh another example where we can use a
layered approach. The defense in depth
approach where you have multiple
conditions hit to detect this popular
click fix attack. Clickfic is not
specifically gena thread but we have
seen certain social engineering aspect
to it and also we recently saw a few
example where they using click fix to uh
deliver agent skills to your computer
malicious agent skills.
So in this rule the super rule I have
three at a high level three conditions
here. So what it at a high level does is
it will check whe the string is
matching. If it matches it will say this
is a clickfix attack and if not it will
go to the similarity check which is
slightly higher cost of uh doing it and
if it doesn't match it will fall back to
the classifier. So in this case uh we
have fine tune a debert model and put it
into the system so that it can detect
these prompt injections.
So three layers together and this
experimental result shows how it works.
As you can see 50% of the threads are
detected by the simple Yara rule and the
remaining roughly 45 to 48% of the
threads are detected by the more
expensive uh similarity and the
classifier threads. So as you can see I
mean one could if you used only the Jara
rule you will be missing 50% of it. But
if you used only for example the
classifier you will be detecting most of
them but it will be more expensive. You
can reduce the cost almost by 50% by
doing a defense in depth layer.
All right. Another important pattern we
all most of the time use is what is
called this pre-filtering pattern.
Instead of always going for the
expensive approach where you can throw
in an LM LLM as I mentioned before, you
can pair LLM with a more cheap operation
like string matching or even a semantic
similarity. So the idea here is whenever
you build rules, you come up with a
string rule and match together with a
classifier or similarity with LLM
something similar to that. uh bend the
cheaper rule with the strong uh more
expensive one so that you are
trying to balance the detection after
pre-filtering it. And this way like in
our experiments we saw actually it was
almost 99% uh reduction in cost when you
do that instead of just blindly throwing
the the most expensive uh construct.
So I'm going to demonstrate that using
this uh real threat which we see
increasingly with geni impersonating
brand has been never been easier. So now
with agents communicating with each
other I'm sure we will see more uh
attacks where agents will be
impersonating the other agents.
All right. So in this case we only have
two rules. The first one is the
classifier rule. uh it's the it acts as
the pref filter and the second rule is
the LLM rule. Uh the classifier is built
from one of the openly available hugging
phase fishing detector. So we just
download that and plug it in. It works
boom there and once
it I mean the problem with the
classifier as I will be showing in the
next slide is it's false positive prone.
So you can't
use the classifier alone to detect it
because it will be a lot of false
positive and the customers will not be
happy and you can still use it as a pref
filter because it's it's okay to get few
false positive as long as it has high
recall and once you get those ones you
can pass it to the second condition LLM.
LLM is more expensive and timeconuming
as as you can see each LLM operation on
average took about 4.5 seconds compared
to the classifier which is few
milliseconds like half a seconds
and
the numbers tell you the story here like
using this pre-filtering approach we
went from hours to minutes to do it and
this is only 10,000 think about like
like usually at paral scale we process
millions of URLs each day this will be a
huge bottleneck if we just throw in the
most expensive operation. And similarly,
the cost, I calculated the cost for the
Gemini 2.5 Pro for 10,000 uh 10 10k
request, and it went from 750 to 13.5 by
doing the pre-filtering.
So, always do the pre-filtering before
you do detections.
And I barely scratched the surface of
the what this library does. It actually
has this flexible philosophy where every
component in the library is pluggable
and it follows the factory pattern and I
didn't talk about the these special
boxes like cleaners and chunkers
whenever when you are dealing with like
messy data like HTML you don't want to
feed the whole data because it has a lot
of fluff which agent doesn't want to see
or any classifier or a semantic model
want to see. So you need to clean it.
There are we have provided from standard
cleaners which will take the HTML remove
all the decorations and get all the the
meat from it and then chunkers because
when you are working with especially
uh generic kind of matching if you try
to match the whole document with one
phrase it's going to give you a very low
score so you probably need to chunk it
or chunk it by sentences chunk it by
paragraphs or do overlapping chunking
there are so many other chunking
techniques you can use the good thing
about the libraries. You can plug in
your own chunkers and cleaners and get
get it working the way you want and you
don't need to change a thing in the
rule. You just need to specify which
chunker you used and then the rule
engine will take care of it. And at the
moment out of the box it supports these
four kind of rules as I mentioned
before. And even for these LLMs you can
use any publicly available Gemini OpenAI
kind of uh model or even you can host it
locally on Oama and call it as well. As
long as you follow the same interface
the contract you can plug in any LLM.
Similar for the classifier and similar
for the uh similarity as well.
All right, the best part of all is it's
all open source. It's available in
GitHub and you just need to go do pip
install Sara. You will get it in your
laptop or whatever device you are using
with and I have website created here all
wcoded and this website has all the
information there. If you go to.org
book, you will see uh not only the gith
pub lib but also some cool examples and
demos of uh different kind of things
because I only demonstrated a very small
uh part of the whole library.
All right, that's it from me. If you
have any questions, I would be happy to
answer.
>> All right, any questions?
Okay, I'm going to start with Moon over
here and then walk over here.
Hey dude, I love Yara. I' I've shared
rules for two decades. This is
fantastic. Um, I had a qu. You're on to
something in terms of like create a
pre-processor, lower the cost, lower the
lower the cost up front in terms of how
many tokens I'm doing, the cost on the
back in terms of my analyst time. Are
you doing any like reverse validation of
new classifiers or new rules to go this
is a good rule, let's deploy it before
you spend 1,300 bucks to find that
answer? Reverse means could you
elaborate more on?
>> Excuse me, I can't hear you.
>> Yeah. Could you elaborate more on that
one? What do you mean by reversing?
>> Uh like uh so if my analysts are
deploying a new rules countermeasure
before it goes through that part of my
CI/CD platform is it's going to go look
at all the malware we've ever looked at
plus a whole collection of stuff that's
like never block this. Um I would
imagine that's a lot harder to do with
classifiers, thus you're saying, "Hey,
use an off-the-shelf one."
>> Um but are you doing any custom ones?
Yeah, I mean I mean there is probably I
didn't explain it here like there is a
part where you want to do some kind of
finetuning. So probably you can see in
the classify there's a threshold part
but that threshold is decided based on
the the ground truth you have in the
CI/CD like you need to use some amount
of known benign and non malicious to
finetune it and yeah I would put it in
shadow before just like in Yara rule
that's what we do we put usually in uh
for about one week in shadow pro because
you never know what you get from the
real field and if it's all good we
enable it in Absolutely. Thank you.
>> All right.
>> I'll do Carl first and then over to you.
>> Yeah. I just had a quick question.
Architecturally, can you explain why you
decided to make a new format with Super
Yara instead of extending the modularity
that Yara already has? Like Yara has PE
analysis that's an an imported module.
uh would that work here or is this
fundamentally changing something about
Yara?
>> I mean it follows the same philosophy. I
mean princ in principle we should be
able to extend it as well but the
friction is high and
in principle we should be able to do it
but yeah we didn't go in that avenue but
it's uh we follow the same footstep of
Vara making it a all open source no
string at edge anyone should be able to
use it.
Um, so that's pretty cool. I didn't know
about this. Uh, Super Yara, I'm a data
scientist, so I'm going to ask a more
data sciency question. Um, so what do
you use uh for routing? Like how do you
decide when uh to use the ML versus the
language model? Do you can you customize
that? Is it like thresholds or is it
other stuff?
>> Yeah, that that's a very good question.
Actually I forgot to mention the the
engine is optimized to uh execute the
cheapest possible rule first if it is or
condition and if it is and condition of
course you'll have to execute both uh
rules and for LLM for specifically it's
all customizable you can have any type
of LLM you just need to wrap around your
LLM call inside the interface provided
as long as you meet the contract you
should be able to use any LLM and the
way I usually decide is I start with the
most powerful one because I want to get
it working and then I lower the version
and try to get it working for the lowest
version I can use so that it will be
cheaper to deploy at at scale.
>> Okay.
Oh, one more question.
>> There you go, Toby.
Following on that question, uh I'm
really curious.
Does your uh matcher stop once it's
found an initial pattern match or does
it continue going and comparing all of
the values that you've got in this uh
the pattern?
>> Uh we can right now it goes through like
especially if you do the chunking and
use it, it'll go through all the chunks
and get the value.
How is it selecting which is the correct
match at that point or is it just giving
you the results of all of the matches?
>> Uh it'll get the best match out of all
like if it match multiple ones it will
identify the multiple ones it identify
the chunks and return it. Okay. Yeah.
And it's very similar to Yara in in Yara
as well. It'll go through everything
like when you even have a Yara rule it
will go through the whole document and
identify all the matches. Similarly
it'll be the same here.
All right,
one more. Okay,
>> so you're saying you are generating all
the coring atoms up front just like Yara
does and then running the conditioners
condition after it.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. And the
>> repeat the question please.
>> Sorry.
>> I was asking if he is running the AO
coric basically is he generating all the
atoms and then having those be submitted
to the conditionals.
>> Yeah. And also these mo models and LLMs
are preloaded so that it doesn't get
loaded every time you run the Lara. it
would be very expensive to do it. So you
initialize it and it will be in the the
global memory and you the rule runs uh
referring to those ones in the memory.